so it's always harder to do that
opposite so maybe it's like a stupidity
thing and to give people courage to go
against the thing that maybe we should
go against more often to challenge
thought to have more critical thinking
sounds
[Music]
lame all right everybody welcome back to
another phenomenal episode of the
careful boys today we have Mr Michael l
in the
building oh we're all going to put on
our do good thinking hats all right
what's dogter you know the guys that do
good that's why it's called do good A
Good Samaritan be nice guy you want me
to explain it more deeply yeah explain
Good Samaritans okay it's um you
remember the Samaritan he's uh Sylvester
Stallone it's a new movie The Good
Samaritan yeah you missed it huh okay
here we go it's a good airplane movie
all right uh if you had the power to
completely solve one social or political
issue affecting the world today what
would it be not global warming I'll tell
you that is that social and political
you're talking about magical right like
like that and then it's fixed you have
that's power stupidity oh I think that's
our biggest problem we [__] stupid
yeah stupidity I don't know if that's
like a a sanctioned social and political
issue but I like that keep going oh you
talking more like build a wall sure and
a sliping my finger I build the wall or
like it's like I slip on my finger and
then no more hungry children sure or
whatever whatever is a like right now I
think like political topics be like but
you can only choose one there's like the
transgender stuff there's like the
there's like the um what's the other one
there's like the immigration stuff yeah
maybe to be a really effective group we
should like list them out so we know
what's on the table and then from there
we can shoot okay there's uh stupidity
is very broad but very good very good
but what's the thing where like the
government has too much power is that a
thing yeah there's when the Govern [__]
the man when government has too much
power it's usually called communism but
yeah usually usually there's that or
like the Hot Topics right now I would
say it's probably the
whole uh Trump indictment thingy there's
that what about taxes anything Financial
anything Financial about human
trafficking I was about to say that man
big I'm like we could be stupid just
don't [__]
kids oh it's it's not even just kids
yeah not not just kids right just like
human trafficking in general that's true
yeah I agree yeah so there's that but is
that even an issue where there's an
opposing group that's saying no we
should keep human trafficking that's
true but they're not they're not not
doing it and then from what I understand
so there's a couple things one it's uh
in the black market industry it's drugs
and then human trafficking yeah I heard
this like it's like a billion dollar
industry billion dollar industry and uh
there are people that believe the people
in power are actually like pedophiles
and [__] and and so like a lot of the
content that we're getting now AKA from
like Disney or whatever is just a giant
brainwashing even the whole like um uh
gender reaffirming for kids let them
choose your sexuality when they're five
or whatever like they think this is a
giant movement and it is the actual like
Pro kid so it's like cuz if the leaders
or are all In Cahoots then it's like
maybe they'll get off the hook if
Society sees this okay yeah yeah and
then you even change the term right it's
not pedophile it's what is it like minor
attracted persons I like like it's just
the
whole like rebranding campaign it's
[__] crazy that's pretty crazy it's
good you got to Rebrand it man cuz it's
like such a stain on someone
reputation I don't think it's a hot
button political issue that's true I
think it's more like it's more like um
everybody everybody doesn't like it yeah
and then we're like how do we solve it
how like it's kind of like world hunger
everybody doesn't like world hunger how
do we solve it it's it's different from
like a I think a political issue was
probably like uh you know a religious
group wants to do it this way an atheist
group wants to do it this way how what's
what's the right way to work it out like
abortion or whatever yeah I I do feel
like with the whole like that situation
I feel like um feel it has to do with
like maybe greed if if that was like a
thing cuz I feel like right now we're at
a thing where poor people are getting
poorer and Rich people are getting
richer and it's like that Gap is just
getting L like right now like anyone
that's working at 95 can't even pay like
can't even get a house compared to like
yeah I think the root of it is is money
yeah but how do you solve a problem
because like human trafficking all those
divisions are are doing what they do
because of the amount of money that they
get um there's even subdivisions of like
the reason why people are being human
trafficked trafficked is because they
end up like killing them and selling
their organs and then that's a whole
another thing too so like finding some
sort of way to level the playing field
when it comes to financials I don't know
what the answer would be but that's why
I was saying the Cure what I would like
to cure is stupidity because the leaders
they make it seem like it's a twoof
front Choice thing right like what do
you want do you want to be on the left
or do you want to be on the right and
you think of these left ideals right
ideals and you think you're the good guy
by choosing the right one whichever one
that is But ultimately it's people are
people and the people that are in the
left and right they're just pitching you
whatever they think is good so they can
make more money right to fit that
narrative so like let's say if Gavin
Newsome is saying by 2030 all cars are
going to be electric there's going to be
zero pollution everyone's like Yay who
knows who he's getting paid off by in
the you know Motor Vehicles industry to
make them say that so ultimately it is a
money thing like you're saying but it
all goes down to it yeah but if we're
too stupid to see that and we're like
dude Gavin Newsome cares about the
environment so much but would curing
stupidity lead to an actual answer of
solving something as Grand as a greed or
financial statement on the grand scope
of society because then it just goes
into like structures of like capitalism
socialism communism and then you're like
what's the answer but what I would try
to prevent is um like be swarming mob
mentality cuz I think when you're stupid
it's easy to get fired up over [__]
you're easily
manipulated people just start tearing
statues down and [__] you know before
like there's no one going wa let's just
chill for like 24 hours it's like you
just hear someone you're like what the
[__] did you just say yeah
yeah so you're putting like the power
back into the people's hands because
they're smart enough to make decisions
yeah make have a couple people go like
yo bro without having like vast majority
of the society just move as that that
type as a giant swarm you know like
everyone just chill out I feel like
social media right now is very bandwagon
like you like even like when you go to
Tik Tok right you when you watch a video
you don't just watch and like you
usually go to the comment section and
you look at the top comments just to see
if like what's the sentiment if yeah
like what's the valid if you're valid or
not or if you don't have anything you
kind of follow what the top nobody wants
to go against the brain everybody wants
to feel like they're saying or doing the
right thing and so it's always harder to
do that opposite so maybe it's like a
stupidity thing and to give people
courage to go against the thing that
maybe we should go against more often to
challenge thought to have more critical
thinking sounds
lame it does it does always always the
good answers sound lame I don't think
there's an answer for like I don't know
I don't know what but hey in this prompt
we have let's say we all have
collectively one Thanos snap to solve a
I was going to say that I was going to
say like you do the Thanos snap you just
[__] half the population dude and if
I go if I go dude I'm out for real you
think we're too populated you think
that's the reason no probably not that's
probably not it but it's more fun to say
that is it more not more fun to say that
we're on our way for a population Deon
we don't even need to do it really yeah
we're having like less babies yeah low
birth rate there's already a graph
showing the trajectory of uh the world
population dropping we peeed yeah oh you
know what I would snap Peak it's over D
cuz I don't even understand this [__]
but I know what happens it's [__]
inflation it's bad right like it' be
cool if they go like this and there's
like this was like I get the point like
okay this used to cost like 500 bucks 20
years later it's like 750 but I'm like
but if we all like that doesn't happen
to My Monopoly box and I play I don't
take out a monopoly box from 20 years
ago and go th000 Bucks worthless and I'm
like how does how is this Collective
money money economy thing how does it
keep going [__] like this you know
according to like financial analyst and
stuff like that that sounds boring
already um lame huh you know the idea
I'm locked in like the reason the reason
why we [__] give billions and
billions and billions of dollars to like
Ukraine and stuff is to fight inflation
on our own soil because the idea because
we're the current current world Reserve
currency right that means the Federal
Reserve is constantly printing money if
we constantly print money and we're
using in our own ecos system that's
where inflation flies so the point is to
constantly print money still and give it
away to other ecosystems so the value of
the dollar is still useful so if you
give it outside if you give it to like
Ukraine in these moments oh that makes
sense and the money becomes more
valuable and useful so it fights
inflation here so that's why no matter
how many people are like why you giving
money over there I'm hly I agree with
them why don't they explain it that way
yeah I've never heard anyone explain it
that way until you y'all heard the great
reset yeah and it would be nice to I
feel like that's going to happen to hear
it from the decision maker yeah you know
like hey I'm doing this because the
narrative doesn't fit as well cuz
they're not going to be like hey we're
only giving this to Ukraine because we
care about ourselves but our American
government does think Americans are
[__] idiots anyway they do and and we
are idiots to a degree abut but it goes
back to the Mob mentality side of like
what is public sentiment going to be
when I tell people why we're doing this
for this reason everyone's going to be
like what the [__] everyone's going to
be pissed and then it's going to cause
more issues I guess but I think that's
just their habit of being like ah let's
just tell them this instead this sounds
it's a better marketing ideal campaign
to say that we're helping Ukraine I mean
either way we're already on like a
[__] ticking Time Bomb because the
dollarization of the world is already
happening and the thing is it might not
fully affect us during our generation
and stuff like that but it's for sure
happening like the dollar is being taken
off the world currency bricks is
expanding they've already got six
nations and they're adding Six Nations
next year you know what I mean so I
think in 5 years we're not even going to
have things are going to be so different
What If instead of dumping billions into
Ukraine cuz you're also uh paying for
more people to die what if they bought
more Bitcoin is there another way to
American Bitcoin yeah I think crypto is
going to come up I think crypto will
always work in some way you know what I
mean like at the end of the day there
was one proposition I thought that was
pretty cool so um this Congressman was
came out with a bill saying that um
people in Congress or like in office
right now they can't own stock and their
Partners can't e either or trade cuz
like you know there's insider trading
going on and another one is they can't
work in the private sector after they
run uh after after they work because
that's that's literally how like Western
corruption Works Western political
Corruptions like third world countries
there's outright corruption in the form
of like Kickbacks and bribery right
whereas the the the legal way we do it
in America is you become a politician
you get into a High position you hook up
the companies that sponsor you so
they're going to sponsor your campaign
for whatever industry different sectors
when you leave office let's say you
write a book you do a book tour right
and then you get paid like half a m
whatever every single time you go to
these events and then you become an
executive on their board a consultant so
it's like how Obama got hooked up with
Netflix afterwards you know he did the
remember the soapa or the the whole
beepa and then the whole like um
internet internet uh it was like
internet there was a word for it it was
it was like censorship or something vag
but it was really to help these
companies out and it's happens for every
presidency every office like whether
every decision-making Department right
like you you hook up your groups and
then when you're done then you get when
you retire is when you make the real
money that's like the guys that work at
fizer and they switch over to the FDA
after exactly and then it's it's not
like or vice versa it's not like they
hide it like you see like the Department
of Health and then you know 5 years
later they're all on the board of fizer
and then it's just clear it's just
people don't research it right so I
think that's they just keep open
corruption cuz all they don't care about
human beings they care about like okay
I'm going to hook these people up then
afterwards I'm going to get paid 8
million 10 million whatever that's the
under the nose [__] right so what you
would just Thanos snap the under the no
[__] I would thanel snap the ability for
politicians to work and like so so for
me I'm like you got to create rules to
where they work in the people's favor
not in the company's favor yeah right
now they're not going to um regulate
themselves like if if we're all
benefiting and we're all like working
like let's say we're all working for the
city of La and then you're the fire
department I'm the police department
we're all going to vote and say hey you
know what I think it would be good if we
all retire with half a million
don't doesn't that sound great and
everyone's like yeah we should do that
right we're all going to back each other
up and then whether they deserve it or
not I don't know you know but at the
same time you can't reg Regulators
aren't going to regulate themselves yeah
so there's no incentive to do no why
would they why would they I like what
Warren Buffett said cuz he said like
he's like I could solve like Congress
whatever corruption or s that corruption
so basically that he was trying to
figure out how we can solve the deficit
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we're in Mad debt
everyone knows that in trillions of
dollars of debt right and then so
they're asking Warren Buffett like how
do we get out of this debt cuz you're a
finance guy and you're a stock guy and
you're really good at Investments and
saving and he goes we won't be in a
deficit
if we make them spend less than 3% of
the GDP so they can that's their budget
there's actually budget so like so what
that means is like there's the GDP like
how much the compan uh the country can
make every year and all that and and and
it's like if you spend more then the
country kind of like economy it's like a
path to to failure so he goes Congress
cannot spend over 3% of the uh GDP if
they do then they all get fired and they
can't get reelected but he says that's
pretty much like the same way all CEOs
get that's how buiness B but the way
America runs is every single time we get
to 2.9% they go all right we need to
make a vote to spend more yeah yeah
every CEO it's like you have to hit
these numbers with this amount of
spending and then now that's where your
CEO creativity really comes into play
but we don't do that for these guys I
have an initiative but that means we
need to have another $5 million and we
keep adding to it bro government is the
only place where you can [__] up and be
a horrible worker but you're still on
the job like for example like in Hawaii
they had they spent 122
billion 12 billion for a track like the
the a train track that no one uses it
took 10 years over like the deadline no
one from that project got fired like
there's you know or like the fire like
happened in Maui like no one's getting
in trouble for how they [__] up
everyone's just blaming each other and I
feel like that's the issue is there's no
limit like they can [__] up multiple
times and they're not in trouble for
anything or getting fired yeah I heard
about the Molly fires that it was it was
planned it was a laser cuz the the um
the land the land is valuable and they
weren't giving they're trying to get it
yeah yes and there was a lot of like Tik
Tok videos like inside residence I think
racism should be legalized though
speaker truth B cuz even in the same
race you're still racist I agree like if
you go to the commercials in Asia they
literally laugh at like the darker
skinned Asians everyone wants to be
lighter skinned across the board Indian
his legalize racism yeah like legalize
it or just end it just just legalize no
he's like legalize it so that we can tax
it monetary benefit if
you so that it's not an issue and make
it part of everyday life you can use
derogatory terms but you have to pay for
it so if you like subscribe to a premium
membership you can [__] cuss
everybody out yeah it's a it's a legal
swear jar yeah okay that's how we fix
our debt that'd be good way all of this
stuff still has to deal with money
though so like you remember you remember
the end of Fight Club you remember how
the concept of the theory was like they
blow up all the [__] credit units and
buildings and stuff like that and then
everybody gets like digitally reset to
zero in order to save the world yeah do
you think that works like if we were to
like Thanos snap and delete all currency
ever if you guys think about good okay
in human history it sounds like things
are going crazy right now but this is
the most peaceful it's ever been this is
the most fed everyone has ever been this
is like dude this is it's a lot of
progress right so a lot of people I
think look at it now and go oh [__]
capitalis but I actually think
capitalism is the best but it's not the
it's not morally ideal it has faults but
definitely better than it's like yeah
but what do you want to do go back to
the medieval system with feudalism and
you know kings and queens and surfs and
you know slaves like what's the best
system communism is still relies on
capitalism it still relies on you know
economics through the coin so um I was
watching these like guys that all they
do is try to create future con STS from
like Living Styles to everything and
then they're talking about trying to
shape it into a resource based economy
not really like a coin economy like a
barter system barter right not barter
but it's more like okay so the
capitalistic value system is create a
good product or service and then you
exchange it for coins right and then
your value is what you produce into the
world if you do it the the the basic way
that's the way you do it like we create
entertainment
someone values that entertainment so
they'll trade it for money but then like
goods and services are are created for
like money right so this whole New
Concept will be things will be produced
but not for the sake of money it will be
for it has to be for a different motive
but it's it's difficult because like one
you know the the negative parts of
capitalism would be like waste cuz
you're producing creating resource
you're using resources and doing all
this stuff for like
random knickknacks that you might not
need so like if everybody were like
piggyback off of Anthony if every if
everybody were to go to zero right
everybody's restart I feel like that
might present more problems and
solutions because people don't have
value to give to each other yeah and
then it goes into war it'll take some
time before people are in a position to
give value and to receive but is that
because there's just too many people and
that goes to the question of
depopulation that's why we got get rid
once we depopulate the place then
everybody has a purpose because there's
only one Baker one Banker one Sheriff
one you know I feel like they will
definitely go into to war everybody's
going to be in fight or flight mode for
a while before it like a system gets
established again if it resets it's just
going to go through what the humans did
previously which is like Hunter gather
farming organ Trail is pretty high you
knowm it's just going to go through the
same stages I don't know I think it's
the best that we have now but I wouldn't
even know how to shift the whole world
to a different way of thinking I think
it works very well cuz I think we all
need some heat on our back like we all
need some competition we need something
to push us move but I feel like right
now like everyone goes to school and in
the schooling system like it sets you up
to be like just like a factory worker
it's old school you're right the reason
why school was invented was because that
was how most people work yeah it just
needs up update cuz back then there was
no internet everybody was a factory
worker whether you worked in massive
plantations where you're picking
pineapples and whatever or you're
canning them or like you're in a paper
mill or like you know it's like
everything is these big factory jobs and
you move up the ranks right yeah it's
either that or you have a family farm or
a small business but I don't I don't
even think that's bad I think it's just
the bad is like if you're going to do
that at least be able to like have that
money be like you can have a livable
life like I feel like right now like no
one everyone wants to do social media
everyone wants to be on the internet
because like if they go to college they
go to debt and then they get a job and
it's like you can't can't live life so
so no no debt free schooling and free
healthcare oh so like Scandinavia yep
great that's what it is everybody listen
to Scandinavia those will seem boring
though no stupid
[Music]
people